hoje falarei de rédeas das cidades é de
tranquilidade
iniesta e tal e novo xodó tendo uma
inovação mais ser a primeira palestra em
portugal a língua do futuro o que será
contar uma história
estamos no ar nos 711 a península
ibérica é dividida entre é trash e
impérios 2010 caiu de 11 11 unidades de
cordel é a principal potência do
continente é também a principal potência
cultural do mundo mas é uma diferença é
muito grande com a estrutural porque é
um país com sua mão
nesse ano serão puderam astúrias
esse pequeno reino do norte onde nasce
da língua que depois virá o português o
regime em que tem 30 humano é uma pessoa
diferente pelo seu tempo ele sabe ler
isso é uma coisa pela nossa loja ainda
mais no século total
ele é um menino um garoto com muita
imaginação mas a imaginação você sabe o
amor à leitura ou da cultura não na coxa
muito valorizada política na oj então
quando você coloca oito em política o
que conta são os números e os números
não era muito boa pra ele me tratou de
cola passou na parte européia do seu
império a 12 milhões de pessoas
o imperium carolinum parei o carro ma
era 8 milhões de pessoas
mas se o reino de astúrias o reino de um
fórum
são 15 mil pessoas
todo mundo pensa no momento que o futuro
de astúrias e está dividido com o futuro
disse a língua que a bolsa língua que a
nossa língua e desaparecer no mapa dos
grandes empresas mas ele tem uma idéia
a ideia é ser economicamente se povoá
semanalmente militar doente final tenho
a oportunidade
a possibilidade está na cultura
queremos a capital mais curta da europa
cristã ea nossa capital tem grau na luz
cultural que impedirá os outros nós
atacar é bonito não é
mas era o mesmo pois é ali mudar a
capital para ouvir o que era antes
antes era um povoado pequeno quando ela
está fazendo construção de tudo o que
uma grande capital da época precisa o
ministério para ter conhecimento uma
grande igreja um palácio
a capital destruída completamente para
uma uma acção por uma invasão muçulmana
e tudo começa
então ele vai lhe um bom vem mas se ele
pensa que é o último rei do sul dos eua
perto e pequenino interno
e finalmente no ano o centro católico
a situação é crítica os carolíngio está
num estágio já ameaçando diretamente a
fronteira se podiam o homem gato uns o
mal está preparando acesso fazendo
incursões o nox e então então um pastor
nunca terrível do ano do ef descobre uma
turma então o rei
o rio tem cano da elle é um milagre é
humilhar ninguém compreende a igreja não
quer aceitar um milagre ele diz não é
humilhada e tanto porque os milagres
fazemos se longe o rei começa e faça um
caminho uma caminhando até a rua do
descobrimento tá começar ele mesmo a
construção de uma igreja como luar está
descobrindo polícia o pastor mas o céu
um de seu especial sérgio estreia
eles chamam o campo da estreia como o
realística que o moto que descobriram o
posto santiado sábado em santiago campos
estela santiago do campo de estrelas
então ele vá de caranguejos menina olha
isso de embater não é tão bom negócio
como isso de fazer um caminho porque
olha se vira popular em toda a europa
que está fácil peregrinação pré santiago
você é a entrada única
você pode controlar você quiser encostos
é muito melhor e cobrar impostos que
paga
soldados e então nós agora somos aliadas
à risca violência que está em nesse
momento também apontou na crise porque é
camargo é muito maior remuneração é essa
inicialmente com a aceitar então o rei
mas survey que é o rei que é e é uma
pessoa interessante ele sabe que o
caminho o caminho não no céu é uma
rodovia
o caminho é sobretudo hospedar e um
caminho sobretudo centros pra encontrar
um caminho sobretudo em mercados o
comércio
então ele começa a falar falar falar com
os monges e começa a construir como essa
do a terra a todo o mundo para elas
construir reconstruir é construir então
que vá passar um verdadeiro milagre um
milagre chamas em população flutuante a
população flutuante fase que as turmas
por primeira vez tenha potência
demográfica tenha inovação tenha
crescimento vá à final porque muita
gente que vá fazendo para a drenagem não
volta cá fica lá e os mercados e com os
mercados em tecnologias
siga o nascimento e com os monges chega
os primeiros livros
então o que havia sido um mero que
baixar no prestígio na cultura de uma
cidade vira um grande triunfo porque é
porque está uma ideia muito importante
uma cidade sozinha não é nada
uma regra de cidades um caminho para
algum lado está a pimenta grande de
se falarmos das cidades o futuro não é
assim
hoje e na europa
estamos numa crise numa grande crise é
uma crise que não é só econômica crise
econômica descobriu muitas outras
crianças que não os que nós temos é uma
delas
acresce cultura é a crise fumega não
podemos fazer nenhuma coisa nenhuma
coisa porque há a prefeitura quebrando
não podemos fazer nenhuma coisa temos
que fechar as portas a migração
sabe por quê por quê porque não temos
espaço para os outros
não podemos ter espaços pra outros
adiante que serra chama seu pau da nossa
gente
você tem que ouvir e ee fund e outra tem
outro porque é porque é um método que
fala inmetro aos touros e as coisas que
produzem outros mensagem exata do do
novo nacionalismo mensagens anti
europeístas os mensagens antissemitas
audi se você consumir com essa feita no
brás eu pulei champô você está
desempregado uma pessoa na história você
está desempregado uma pessoa infância
você estava empregando uma pessoa em
inglaterra
você sabe o médico é muito anterior nós
temos que descobrir a verdade da
história que é adaptada na história do
nosso raio fãs
é pra isso temos que construir uma nova
peregrinação hoje a peregrinação não é a
peregrinação do apóstolo onde aprendi
nação ea peregrinação do conhecimento
hoje a peregrinação que a agremiação
pelas novas oportunidades
hoje a peregrinação
é a pesquisa de uma nova riqueza para as
nossas cidades das bossas cidade sobre
uma nova população flutuante
a boa notícia é que nós só começamos que
começamos em três grandes cidades do que
a minha missão é igual e booth de
cidades muito diferente se fala a língua
se diferencie falamos cinco línguas em
três cidades mais diversidade não é
possível que queriam fazer aquela mas
vocês combinar o primeiro os pegaria o
pds mas as suas periferias e oito
workshops
isso é só respeitar ilhas está a oferta
quando uma pessoa trabalha em um coach
da regra tem um espaço ea possibilidade
de terra a agenda é ficar com novos
clientes e ficar com novos mercados em
tudo os seus espaços o golpe
nós queremos gente pensar nós todos o
seu trabalho na sua cidade
mas o seu trabalho na rege o país
adiante do caminho é a rede mesh com
isso a idéia segundo nós não é uma
história muito bonita
o filho do rei afonso o primeiro grande
é difícil que construiu
você sabe que ela era uma sala de festas
de santa maria garante é uma beleza
entre muito mais fino que nenhuma grécia
igreja na época porque se você está
fazendo um caminho você também precisa
um espaço pra festejar pra celebrar
porque é isso que faz a comunidade
então hoje é o mesmo se o rei precisava
uma sala de festas e precisava de mons
eu precisava de conhecimento nós
precisamos uma universidade
nós precisamos do desenvolveu um nôvo
connect conhecimento que conhecimento o
conhecimento do compartilhar a nova
economia colaborativa não vai com
nomeada compatilhar tem que ser a
ferramenta para nós possuir os novos
mercados novos e em fatos novos modelos
de negócio baseado na cooperação e temos
que fazer é o veto isso os modelos de
negócio porque porque queremos uma rede
que não tenha fim
a diferença do caminho uma renda não tem
começo não tem fim
então se queremos criar excesso que não
sei a que se queremos compartilhar como
o zé é compartilhar com você com os
americanos de construir aliás o
conhecimento
o novo conhecimento de toda essa gente
sanguinário que está fazendo uma nova
economia que não é que não está baixando
na esquema que não estava salva no
individualismo que não está a passar na
instrução que está avançada mas que está
avançada na criatividade
o compartilhar ea sua ea
sustentabilidade da nossa relação entre
nós eo mundo e pensamos que o espaço do
mercado mesmo é a cidade porque você
sabe o principal serviço público são o
suficiente
são os filhos que faz mais por outro
nós temos estudado em austrália espanha
estados unidos novos sistemas nos
sistemas de combater a entrar gente com
a crise
queremos produzir não só para traduzir
num software uma nova não monastério
para desenvolvedores e salva livre e
salva distribuído
o objetivo
a minha proposta da chapa para vocês é
se você tem um carro aqui você tem um nó
não sabe ainda se você quer
se você tem um projeto você tem um
mercado que você tem
como tem muita gente com ouvidos
esperando por um grupo do cs em portugal
espanha frança mensagem é é o tempo de
fazer o caminho é o tempo de cruzar o
mar é o tempo da cheka uma nova regra
para todos sucesso e nada e
independentemente do que vocês ouvem na
televisão ao invés de algumas mensagens
políticos europeus pra nós
as portas são abertas necessitamos de
vocês e vocês ao agravo e persa
muito obrigado
efe